why are we sending money my opinion is
we should not be sending a dime to
Ukraine what is the justification for
that it is a deeply deeply corrupt
government that has been elevated by
most of the hard left in this country as
another America they present it as if
it's this great Democratic Republic it
is not it is not and if the if the new
if the new uh Mantra here is that we
need to intervene every time Putin does
something or every time to what end so
I'm just trying to figure out the
long-term strategy of that is that that
we get involved and send financial and
otherwise assistance to every country
when this happens why is Ukraine
different why did isn't it interesting
to everybody that the entire American
Media jumped on board with this talking
point from the get-go the entire
American Media on the left who is
largely inter non-interventionists at
their core why are they suddenly so
passionate about us sending a ton of
money to Ukraine and why has zelenski
become this I mean you see him as if
he's the second coming of Christ so I I
find that high suspicious in a car in a
government that's deeply deeply corrupt
um again not this is not America number
two and by a lot of people who generally
speaking are very much stay out of it
unless they come at us it's none of our
business stay out of it that suddenly
have this heavily interventionist
approach I find it all highly suspicious
I don't think we should so at all you
bring up some very valid points right
there and if it was just the U.S that
was basically funding this operation I
would have legitimate questions as to
what's going on but when the entire EU
and a NATO who's on that side of the
world is basically saying yeah we're on
team Ukraine yeah that's kind of makes a
little bit more sense to me so if it was
just the United States I clearly hear
you on that but I don't know something
about what is the Strategic interest for
us though in getting involved in Ukraine
in particular and is there going to be a
strategic interest in getting involved
in Finland in every area that Putin
decides to or not to touch what is the
Strategic American interest in doing
that yeah I mean that's something that
you should ask Anthony blinken but well
I don't need to ask Anthony Blakely
because it doesn't exist so you're
basically so the question I have is
you're just okay with strong men
basically recreating borders no that I
mean listen that's a legitimate question
though Jeff no I mean do I love Putin no
am I a Putin fan do I wear a Putin shirt
no I don't but there has to be a reason
for involvement if you're gonna send
first of all this country is broke we
are broke the people of this country are
broke there is no justification for
sending money out unless there's a
strategic interest for the United States
you know this whole America First we're
done we're people are struggling here
they can't put food on their table the
gas price is this that everybody wants
to complain about that and then it's
like oh let's send more money if we are
going to send our money out and we are
going to poke the bear over there which
we are doing and we are going to to
invite a higher level of risk assessment
for people in the United States with
every move we make than their damn
weather be damn well better be uh uh
strategic interest that can be
delineated that's clear and a long-term
plan I don't see either of those things
and I see a deeply corrupt government
that we're rushing to defend with no
justification so my 100 vote is stay out
of it that doesn't mean I endorse Putin
that means that not not every instance
will warrant United States intervention
and justify that and in this case it
does not I'm totally okay with being
non-interventionalist hundred percent I
mean that money is being yeah but it's a
different thing this is a proxy war this
isn't [ __ ] Vietnam this isn't the
disaster that happened in Iraq and
Afghanistan if anything we've learned
our lesson that we can't send our troops
into these countries to try to make a
difference why are we sending our money
well because that's basically the what
we have the resources that we don't do
of course we do we don't have it we just
talked about the debt we don't have it
people we don't have that money to spend
that's extra we don't have that money we
we could we could easily Tyler brings up
the Border everybody wants to laugh
about that but we can easily take that
money and put it toward defending our
own borders and where we have a flood of
dangerous drug cartels that are coming
across the Texas border every day nobody
seems to care about take that money that
we're sending over to Ukraine and
actually do something to protect our own
border from this influx of Horror that's
affecting you know a human trafficking
surge that's a disaster we have plenty
of things that that money needs to go to
that it's currently being sent to
Ukraine where there is no strategic
interest so I think it's no-brainer and
I think there is something deeply
corrupt going on
um at the high government level that is
that is then filtering out two media
that is encouraging this and it's very
dangerous in practice mentioned that
article about uh us this one is from
Reuters where U.S warns Putin of
catastrophic consequences of nuclear
weapon used in Ukraine and U.S would
respond decisively to any Russian use
what does that mean respond decisively
you're going to enter a war with Russia
now over Ukraine this is utterly insane
this is we are now in insane Turf um and
it just it's it's
it's wakadoo well and Adam my point with
Crimea only six people died so they
estimate 80 000 Russians have been
killed in this conflict how many do you
think would have died if the United
States wasn't sending weapons money
ammunition funding arming to the
Ukrainian Army yeah well I mean if you
want to know a larger strategy the
United States probably has is they would
love to see Putin out of office and if
you're seeing what's happening right now
in Russia and then you just what called
up that 300 000 reservists
people are protesting okay so you have a
strong man in Russia they don't even
have it's not even oligarchy it's a
freaking thugocracy okay it's him and
his thugs basically just siphoning off
money for themselves and just doing what
they want in the country and I think at
the at the end of the day United States
this is not something that we stand for
now we can kind of go about different
you know ways of basically dealing with
him well who's right and who's wrong but
if in terms of values and principles of
what we stand for in America Russia and
Putin is not it so neither is what's
going on Andrew zielinski in Ukraine
though that's the thing it's been
glorified it's been twisted and
destroyed and you're not wrong about
that for that either so why we don't
stand for any of it so stay out of it
you know like and and this government
stays out plenty remember the Iranian
revolutions during the Obama years we
stayed out of that why people were
saying oh that they're in the streets
they're talking about Freedom they're
talking about Freedom they need help
they need help and they're like no no no
no no let's not even get involved in
there so this this something this is
something deeply corrupt and political
because if we were going to get involved
that's internal was there a proxy war
that we could have fight in Iran but but
there's nobody there's nobody to fund
but how are we going to fund people
right but there was not even but it
would call for that by the by the the
hard left in this country that's now
putting zielinski on posters outside
it's like you got to have you know on
Twitter it's like you've got your your
gender pronouns and then you've got your
Ukrainian flag and you've got a big
picture of zelenski why that's that
tells you there's something deeply
disturbing going on here if you if you
can't outline the Strategic interest for
the United States and it's just well
Putin is bad Putin is bad what's going
on in Ukraine under a deeply corrupt
government is bad it's none of our
business so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]